there's a gap between the world and the
things that trigger you and your
response and your entire life is that
gap I can't concentrate I can't think
I'm not learning I can't focus raha and
you freak out
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation at 7:00 my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent adds something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message control how you live
over to you Mel Robbins you know I'm
always looking for new ways to explain
the power of the 5-second role in the
power of 5-second decisions and I read
something that Tim Ferriss said that
really resonated with me and he had this
one line buried in a podcast somewhere
that just jumped out and it's it's it's
stuck and what he said is he said
something about how there's a gap
between the world and the things that
trigger you and your response and your
entire life is that gap when you start
to this is not what he said he I kind of
identified this gap and I of course
intrinsically was like well absolutely
that's the five-second window between
instinct or stimulus and your reaction
and when you start to understand that
your whole life plays out in this
five-second gap and that there's a gap
that's five seconds long between fear
and courage and there's a gap that's
five seconds long between self-doubt and
confidence that is your life and what's
super cool about understanding that your
whole life is inside this gap is it's so
small everybody that you have the
ability to control it life's always
going to throw triggers at you and there
will always be all kinds of cool things
that inspire you your wisdom and you get
to
what happens in that gap do you succumb
to an excuse or do you push yourself
forward when you start to speak up in
business you'll be shocked at how you
start to speak up and your relationships
when you start to make hard phone calls
whether it's in a selling situation
you'll be surprised at how you'll start
to close the gap and have hard
conversations in your personal life and
so that gap is everywhere and it's the
same everywhere and when you start to go
to work in controlling how you live in
that gap between stimulus or idea and
your response that's where the magic is
so Shakespeare said there's nothing
either good or bad but thinking makes it
so and I think it's true nothing is
actually inherently good or bad it's
your attitude it's your approach it's
how you interpret it that then changes
the course of your life there are some
people who walk around and they can find
a way to be negative about everything
you know some of these people they are
just always negative something is always
wrong there's always drama that that
circulates them that follows them that
they didn't want to inflict on other
people they're just really unhappy
people constantly and these others who
are positive we're optimistic always
seem to be happy always seem to be
smiling and those are the people that
you want to be around why like they
might have the same light there they
might work in the same building and yet
one is negative one is positive they're
just interpreting things differently the
positive one chooses to see the good and
negative ones chooses to see the bad and
everything that happens and so people
ask me how am I always positive and
optimistic and upbeat and is this an act
like this is who I am what I share on
this channel here this is me this is who
I am I don't go after pressing stop and
then hate my life like I'm a positive
upbeat guy I just choose to see the good
in things I think this is an amazing
world I think no matter what's happening
in the world that that we will win that
yeah I'm on board with Team humanity
like it's gonna be great we will solve
these problems this is the best time
ever to live and and even that line of
it's the best is something that came up
recently at my workshop in Toronto at
this workshop helping people make money
from their ideas was 3-day event and one
of the things that came up over and over
and over again is it's the best like
anytime we had a little problem that
happened my dog peed on the floor one
time this fire alarm went off is like
it's the best this is awesome
take the fire alarm for example you know
I'd split people up into three different
groups they were in three different
locations fire alarm goes off it's easy
to get agitated by it I'm trying to
learn here I'm trying to understand this
message why is this fire alarm going off
I can't concentrate I can't think I'm
not learning I can't focus raha ah and
you freaked out the fire alarm is going
off anyway freaking out and getting
angry is not gonna solve anything right
so what I did was I walked around to
each of the three groups I said guys is
the best like being able to learn
through this situation it's the best now
it's not that you welcome problems you
want problems to calm you you want all
this negativity in your life you don't
welcome it you don't want it to come
you're not saying hey problems please
come find me but when they come what's
your reaction to it problems are coming
for you they come for everybody do you
see this big overwhelming thing that you
get frustrated and angry I want to
complain about or is it the best and you
make the best of it and you find your
way through now that's easy when it's a
fire alarm or when the dog pees on the
floor when you're stuck at a traffic
light or an elevator and you get
frustrated and you want to turn that
into it's the best great what do you do
when it's actually a major problem what
do you do if it's somebody in your
family dies or has cancer or there's
abuse or drug use or all of the negative
stuff that happens in our lives how do
you turn that into a positive before you
throw tomatoes at me let me let me try
to shift your perspective and say that
it's the best I'm a big believer that
your purpose comes from your pain if you
look at the people that have done the
most the most good for the world it
comes from a deep source of pain my
passion to help entrepreneurs comes from
my feeling unworthy as an entrepreneur
when I first got started and how low I
felt of myself having no self-esteem
self-confidence because I worked because
I wasn't making any money and I just
felt worthless as a human being and I
don't want other people to have to go
through that we looked at people came to
my workshop and their purpose their
mission what they are so excited for
that the big change you're trying to
make in the world is coming from their
own struggles growing up from massive
points of pain and the pain that they
went through some of them is is
you know you wouldn't wish that on your
biggest enemy but because they went
through it because they survived it
because they dealt with it
they developed coping mechanisms for it
now they want to make sure that that one
that never happens to anybody else ever
again and to that the people who it does
happen to they want to help them not
have to feel the same pain they want to
help them know that they're not alone
they want to give them different coping
mechanisms to deal with it and so yes
even in these really negative deep dark
extremely painful places if you can
learn to say this is the best to still
feel the pain to know that this sucks
but to know that getting through it
makes you stronger gives you purpose and
will allow you to help other people if
you can find in your heart to say this
is the best that's when your life really
starts to change and so nothing is
either good or bad but thinking makes it
so
I've got a really special bonus clip
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that I want to know question of
the day what is one negative that has
happened in your life
big or small recently that you have
turned it into a positive I made it into
something that has benefited you your
family your friends your community your
customers I want to know leave in the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
expresso keep me
in the journey of life as well the
takeoff which is a birth is completely
beyond our control we didn't choose our
parents we didn't choose which nation we
Bhuvana
we didn't choose which city paper bonnet
we didn't choose a socio-economic class
we were born in we didn't choose our
looks we didn't choose the religion
we've abandoned our takeoff of the
journey of life was completely beyond us
and the landing death even that will be
completely beyond us I've heard many
times people telling me that they would
just love to die by getting a massive
heart attack and dropping dead no
trouble for them no hospitalization no
tubes no needles no trouble cause two
others in one shot go now no matter how
much we might wish that it's just beyond
us how we go and how the landing happens
is completely beyond us and what about
the turbulence the disturbances the
problems during the journey of our life
some of them are within our control
which we can solve for many problems and
issues and the turbulence caused is
completely beyond the control because
it's caused by situations which are
beyond us it's caused by people who are
beyond us yes ladies and gentlemen in
this journey of life the take-off the
planning and the turbulence is not in
our control what is in our control
however is the choices we can make
and therefore spirituality is about
learning how to make those right choices
when we learn to make those right
choices we learn to live a transformed
happy fulfilled life despite all the
turbulence and problems that are going
on around
it is said when we are beautiful it's
God's gift to us when we live our life
beautiful it is our gift to God
therefore being a meal is a matter of
birth being a man is a matter of age
being a gentleman is a matter of choice
and as a corollary to that being a
female is a matter of birth being a
woman is a matter of age being a
gentlewoman is a matter of choice let us
all take to spiritual wisdom learn to
make the right choices which have the
dinner control as our gift to God and
thus live our lives as thorough and
perfect ladies and gentlemen if you tell
yourself a story long enough you start
to believe it don't you believe you act
like I am Tulsa what a wail out of a
handcuffed lightning though Thunder in
jail now you know I'm bad over the last
week I've murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between eighteen
and two hundred and fifty four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for two
hundred fifty four days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around making you feel
confident it's absolutely free check out
the link in the description below to get
access